Boulder City settling a lawsuit against
two former employees who sued the city
due to what they claim was religious
discrimination within the Mormon faith
but it's the amount the city settled for
that has a lot of residents up in arms
it's a story you'll only see on eight
news now Madison Kimbrough was at the
city council meeting today joins us now
from Boulder City with more
it's a done deal as Boulder City Council
approves a 1.7 million dollar payout to
the former city manager and City
attorney as they were fired in 2020 and
those in the community not pleased with
how things turned out we had several
people comment including myself and
former mayor McManus and had lots to say
about it
and nothing nothing didn't seem to
matter Sharon Newby feels unheard after
Tuesday's Boulder City council meeting
mayor Joe Hardy and members of the
Council made their final decision in
regards to a lawsuit between two former
city employees all those in favor say
aye aye in the lawsuit former city
manager Alfonso noyola and former City
attorney Steve Morris suing the city due
to claims of religious discrimination
after being fired in 2020. the city has
won at virtually every step of the
judicial process Boulder City taking
this lawsuit to court with the Supreme
Court giving the city the option to
settle by May or have the Court decide
their outcomes we're a small City and
1.7 million dollars is a lot of of money
in the end the city decided to pay out
Loyola and Morris totaling just over 1.7
million dollars to settle out of court
and residents Like Pat Murphy confused
as to why it doesn't seem right
to do that without talking to the people
of Boulder City about what's your
reasoning why did you decide not to take
this to court any further and as for
where this money will come from there's
a possibility that the insurance will
pay for it the city's insurance but if
that doesn't happen then it will come
out of the risk management fund and in a
statement sent exclusively to eight news
now Boulder City Mayor John Hardy
stating this quote I believe that it's
in the best interest of all parties
involved to put this behind us claims by
affected parties are hereby resolved
reporting here in Boulder City Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now